all right everybody welcome back and we
are at it uh again let's go
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
welcome back
out at CNN out at Fox let's talk about
it
found some interesting Instagram posts
that people have sent me want to get
into that NBA is just like it's actually
making me re fall in love with the NBA
this playoffs have been fantastic
[Music]
couple more news and notes but his
overall it's all me baby welcome back
my voice is terrible
oh my God I'm so sorry
yeah I don't know what's going on with
me oh what come on shut up and that came
on again anyway welcome back to River
Griffin sorry my voice has just been
crackling race recently I think I'm
allergic to something man I gotta have
the people come check the AC filters you
know but anyways whatever welcome back
to riffing with Griffin y'all this is
riffford with Griffin every Wednesday
uh you know this is me Eric Griffin
comedy podcast sometimes it's comedy
sometimes it's news sometimes I'm
serious sometimes I'm not but I'm always
100 me so if you've been here before you
know what to expect if you're someone
new welcome you know welcome you were
you we're in for just I'm doing it off
the cuff it's live and here we are so
thanks for being here so we're from with
Griffin go to Eric griffin.com for all
things Eric Griffin thank you Please
Subscribe hit the notifications button
so you know when I go live sometime on
Wednesday morning I'm trying to go live
like I'm trying to be more consistent
and be at 10 A.M but sometimes you know
life gets in the way I'm on Twitch most
days I'm gonna be on Twitch later today
so you can check me out Eric Griffin
gaming on Twitch and I have Eric Griffin
gaming on on YouTube you can see all my
some of my older videos you can support
me in so many ways you could be a member
uh you could be a twitch sub uh you
could be a patreon person just if you
want to support and I appreciate that
all right I do appreciate that
um let's see I am gonna be
I'm at the mothership this weekend
really looking forward to that you know
um let's see what some shows I have
coming up if you want to check that out
you know let's see on my my crazy
website um I already did the Blue Room
that's done Louisville Comedy Club this
past weekend was great so I'm at the
comedy Mothership and but according to
the website all the shows are sold out
so yeah baby really nothing in May I
gotta get my I have a couple more dates
and stuff coming up but for now this is
what it's looking like right now so look
out for that in uh the future Eric
Griffin
dot com if you want to come check me out
live I am hilarious I'm just telling you
that right now I am hilarious
so what happened this week okay so
crackers update if you know from last
week's episode
they are still
in the living room okay they are still
in the living room Rachel has not moved
the crackers so
we'll just keep you updated on how many
weeks those crackers are gonna be
sitting on that table in the living room
you know it's like that's just what
happens in relationships you know
um but anyways let's just get into some
comments uh a lot of people had some
comments uh from uh previous last week's
episode
let's see here
um
uh let's see Darcy Bennett oh she people
love commenting on my Matt Rife episode
she goes I know this is old but the
thing about La chicks it's still True to
this day certain age range but true I
live there I'm older lol I don't even
know what that's a what that even refers
to
Maverick Miller rap recap with straight
gas with three fire emojis thank you
um
mrd1228 said do you agree that if the
NBA would play less games that we'd be
more interested from fans and also less
injuries in the playoffs finals also
playing three instead of seven because
we we can tell who the best team is from
best of three instead of dragging it out
so long
um I think if they
I don't know I think that the play style
of this modern era of basketball it's so
much more open and running up and down
the court that these that it's going to
be hard to not get injuries the way
they're playing I mean it's not natural
to play a professional sport
three four times a week to do that to
your body
it's gonna be in and especially if these
guys aren't being professional
that's what we're starting to see is
like that you really have to take care
of your body like LeBron James is
showing you the way LeBron is like look
I'm 38 years old but I spent a lot of
money on my body so people could come
watch me play so I could continue to
play for 20 years what's gonna have to
happen is the players are gonna have to
take it way more serious because of the
playstyle and the NBA should consider
you know changing maybe they you know
have less games
but you know it's all about money and I
like the seven game series in the
playoffs let's find out who the best are
says you know I don't mind a good seven
game series I mean the playoff NBA
playoffs is a whole other season of of a
sport and I I like it a lot
Amanda Howell Eric you're the best I
love those kind of comments thank you
uh uh let's see
um oh so Jessica are we a relano or
Rihanna because I think it's Double L is
a y I don't know I'm terrible remember
the whole thing about I was asking
people about like because Rachel and I
are both messy so she says husband and I
both are neat freaks but I'm a bit more
OCD our version of your cracker problem
are the bath towels if I don't change
them out we would use the same dirty
towels for his entire life
I mean yeah
Rachel about that kind of stuff she is
like that she will
change the sheets to towels all that
kind of stuff she makes sure I use the
towel once and she'll grab it put it in
the thing and I'm like where's my towel
you know what I mean she especially will
only use a towel once
so that's interesting
um let's see if you guys get some more
comments in
uh
let's see
John Reddin love your movie TV reviews
thank you Eric Flores I've always been
the messy one until I hooked up with my
girl she is worse than me and it forced
me to be the clean one yeah
I know what you you know what I'm in the
same situation
like I hate washing dishes and all that
but I have to do it you know what I mean
because if I don't do it here's another
one Steve Beck we are both clean freaks
there are times that I lack and she
picks up the slack and vice versa when
we both are in the clean mode watch out
that's that's yeah I guess Rachel and I
are like that too like like one day I
was like okay I gotta clean the bathroom
then I clean the bathroom and the next
thing you know she cleaned so it's like
I triggered her to clean
but anyways guys thanks for the comments
thanks for interacting you know continue
to do that thanks for everybody that's
watching live right now on YouTube uh
thanks to everybody that's listening
later on all the all the platforms that
you listen to you know I appreciate I
appreciate all of that
um
yeah I appreciate it all right let's
just get right into some NBA talk real
quick you know NBA playoffs are just
really
you know what I if you've been listening
to my
podcast you know that I've just kind of
been sort of like disenchanted with the
NBA recently but I gotta say I like it
even though there's some nonsense that's
going on you know my clippers I'm a
Clipper fan
I'm a Clipper fan and I'm really
disappointed
actually the Clippers are cursed man if
you go back to even with Chris Paul
Blake Griffin DeAndre Jordan were there
and we just never
we never got a chance to even make a
finals appearance even though we had the
team to do it
Chris Paul and his prime Blake Griffin
in his prime DeAndre Jordan is prime JJ
Redick on that shooting we had Matt
Barnes I mean we had the team to do it
but it was always something Chris Paul
getting hurt Blake Griffin getting hurt
or choking in against up 3-1 you know it
was it's just always was something with
the clippers but the injuries
have plagued us for years
so now you got this we get Kawhi Leonard
coming off a championship we think wow
this guy he's already won two
championships with two other franchises
and we think oh this is going to be it
Kawhi Leonard's gonna do it let's do
this dude is always hurt like always
hurt when it counts Paul George another
one
just always hurt
every chance he gets he gonna get hurt
it's like oh does it matter right now
yeah boom his body lets him down it's
it's really a shame I really feel sorry
for these two guys I feel sorry for the
Clipper fan base
you know I know they're not faking them
it's just one of those things I mean
playing sports is tough
at such a high level and you know
especially when I think the greater the
player is the more chance they are to
get hurt because they're playing at such
a great level and they're doing like
just superhuman type stuff and their
bodies really can't handle it
from all reports Kawhi Leonard takes
care of his body and works really hard
he just has zero personality you know
and it sucks to find out that his sister
his sister murdered somebody and just
got sentenced the other day no I didn't
even know that and you know he probably
distanced himself from his sister he was
like yeah you know
that sucks you know you have it sucks
that that says a lot about what's going
on in their family you know that they're
obviously they're not close
because like
if you close with your sister you know
you taking care of her she don't gotta
rob a casino in Temecula and kill
someone right so they obviously haven't
had a relationship in a long time and
then you know you have everybody judging
him based off like what that's your
family man but it's not his fault you
know what I mean sometimes family family
are the worst you don't get to pick your
family you get to pick your friends
always remember that sometimes family
ain't [__] so anyways so I feel bad for
my clippers you know and I think that
even with just Kawhi Leonard or just
Paul George they would have beat the
sons all right so then that's just crazy
so then you know you got the sons
you know you got the sons you got Kevin
Durant you think all right Kevin
Durant's doing it but I gotta say man
with Kevin Durant's presence on the
court and what he's doing it's making
Devin Booker shine if they go all the
way Devin Booker is going to be the MVP
he's going to be the finals MVP because
he is balling
okay so but they don't have enough they
have a six-man rotation that's not gonna
be good against these other teams I
think Denver is going to beat them uh
you know I picked the Clippers to beat
the Suns and I believe that they would
have beat them if Kawhi Leonard was
healthy I mean they were it's terrible
and I feel bad for Russell Westbrook
another one so anyways NBA playoffs are
heating up you know you got Denver
you got this great series with
Sacramento and Golden State uh Darren
Fox is injured but he's I think he's
still gonna play tonight so we'll see
how that goes that's a great series I
think whoever wins tonight wins the
series you can't count the Champs out I
think Sacramento has a better team but
you just can't you know the heart of a
champion right you know Steph Curry
who knows I would not be surprised if
either team won if the number three seed
one I'm not gonna be surprised if the if
the reigning Champs win I'm not gonna be
surprised so we'll see what happens
great series man uh Darren Fox is
turning into a bona fide star and it's
about time everybody recognized that
um what else all right Lakers look man
I can't say enough about LeBron James
what a professional athlete this guy is
20 years in the league 38 almost 39
years old
and there are times on the court where
he is the best player in the league the
way he's playing
in these moments
is he should be an example to every
professional athlete him and Tom Brady
all those people that could play late
and he spends money on his body because
he's like this is my job my job is to be
in shape and ready to go
kudos to him what a series he's having
they're up 3-1 I think the Lakers should
go on and we'll see what happens in the
next series I think they have a size and
physicality advantage on both the Kings
and the Warriors
so we'll see what happens to do that 20
something points and 20 rebounds man 20
rebounds and then in the end in the last
game and then Dylan Brooks let's talk
about Dylan Brooks the dude that runs
his mouth and I like to poke Bears he
said right he likes to poke Bears well
he got poked back he got demolished okay
he was nowhere to be found you know in
the game after talking smack he punches
LeBron in the balls even if it was by
accident he had to get thrown out he
wasn't having a good game he's shooting
three for whatever
and then in this game they have a chance
to win the game they just need to stop
LeBron takes him to the rack and one and
then the guy that runs his mouth
constantly
doesn't want to talk to the Press he
just exits he just he doesn't want to
talk to the Press what's that man
you know what you made it fun you were
talking smack you poking the bear own it
come out and be like all right the old
man got me old man got me uh but we
coming back say something man just to
like punk out like that
ugh
ugh man ugh
now on the East Eastern side last night
uh Trey young did some Trey young things
Murray was out I thought the Celtics for
sure were gonna end this series and they
didn't and this is what my issue is with
the Celtics
this coach does not have experience in
this situation and it's going to show
the Celtics need the email doku I think
would have been a better voice for them
going into this year but you all know
what happened with that this coach is
not ready for this situation I think and
I think the Celtics are going to go down
not to the Hawks I think the Hawks you
know they're going to beat the Hawks
Trey young just did some Trey young
things last night it was great great
game
he this dude he he accounted for almost
80 points of their score with assists in
his own scoring the dude is fantastic he
had a fantastic game he rose to the
occasion in the playoffs
Celtics are believing gonna win this
series
okay and then you got Jimmy Butler the
Heat versus the number one seed the
Bucks Giannis got hurt I don't think
they're gonna recover I don't think
Giannis is 100 and I don't want to see
him in the playoffs anymore I'll wait
till next year he's he's just it's not
gonna happen this year for the bucks
there's no way that if he's injured he's
gonna be able to recover when they're
gonna be playing every other day for the
next you know five weeks or however long
the playoffs so I don't want a 80 80
Giannis I want 100 Giannis so get him
out I think I think Miami's gonna win
this series they're up 3-1 Jimmy Butler
goes Jimmy Butler goes for 56 points on
them okay 56
the next closest player on the Heat have
15 points like just stop this one guy
they win I'm I'm done with the Bucks and
that means with the Bucks out okay Miami
going on then they play then they're
gonna play probably the Knicks because
the Knicks are beating Cleveland
Cleveland's choking so the next Miami I
think the Knicks can beat Miami I think
you'll see the Knicks in the in the
Eastern Conference Finals versus the
Sixers I think the Sixers are gonna be
the team that's gonna come out of the
East because everybody else is too
compromised and can't be trusted I think
the Sixers can be trusted Joel and B
went down and they still came and won
that game James Harden stepped up I
think James Harden has a lot to prove I
think Joel and B is going to win the MVP
and so then he's gonna come out and be
like this is going to be their year
finally I think they're going to get
over the hump Doc Rivers is going to get
over the hump and I think this is going
to be it for the I think the Sixers go
to the championship that's my prediction
well you know I gotta be wrong
um yeah yeah well yeah that's my NBA
talk
that's my NBA talk thanks for being here
for the NBA talk okay
um all right guys let's get into some
big news big news this is big news big
news for big people man
big news for big people let's see is
this is this gonna work wait what's
going on here oh wait I have to turn
this off there we go
all right yeah baby look at those two
guys
probably the two of the most polarizing
guys in news
so this past week
shock shocking development
um
oh here's my nasal spray you guys mind
if I do my allergy nasal spray
all right there we go
um
Tucker Carlson and Don Lemon out
they're out can you believe this
so I don't know the whole story
you know I just like talking about stuff
so I have it I have it up here on my uh
screen here so here's what I first of
all let's go to Don Lemon first
I think Don Lemon just is like
you know he's talking about things wait
hold on a second
sorry Don lemon's talking about things
that you're not supposed to talk about
on the news it's too nuanced right like
you could have a nuanced discussion
about things
but that don't mean it's meant for the
news it's not meant for TV when you're
when your network has an agenda okay so
this is a very liberal news organization
that you know they're you know they're
out here with that left agenda and it's
like everything that's going on cancel
culture everything with that you know
they're on that side and he has to tow
the company line and I just feel like he
got to a point where he was just like
feeling himself what happens is these
guys think they're bigger than the
networks themselves they think that they
are like okay my ratings are so high or
whatever and now I can say yeah you
can't do that
you know so one of the things
he he wrote that he was stunned but one
of the big things that he got in trouble
for was he was talking about
um what was he he was talking about
um
some lady right and she said she was
past her prime
was not in her prime
uh about Republican Nikki Haley 51 was
not in her prime now listen I don't know
what he was talking about
you know
that's a sin like it becomes a sensitive
issue
you can infer what you think he's
talking about but let me just say this
if we were talking about athletes okay
if I was talking about Aaron Rodgers and
I said yeah Aaron Rodgers has passed his
prime is that an insult
is it an insult no it's not in that
situation what I'm talking about is this
guy is not at his athletic height
anymore still great player still good
but he has passed his prime okay
you can say that no issues what was he
talking about he didn't clarify is he
saying she's passed her political Prime
is she is she as she passed the time
when it was time you know uh she would
have been better off running five years
ago 10 years ago because of a b and c
factors
he didn't clarify anything he just said
this and then what happens is people run
with this and now they make it about
what about her being an older woman and
now it just becomes about that so
you know what I mean so it's just I'm
51. you know what I'm saying so I
I get
he deserves this criticism because it's
it's a it's a statement that needs to be
unpacked and clarified
it's nothing wrong like if he's talking
about her political Prime he could be
right but what was he talking about and
so he just seems to me have gotten a
little lazy you know and then he got and
then it was that comment and then he was
talking about the women's soccer it was
like what a men's soccer is more
interesting that's a comment you could
believe that you don't need to stay on
air okay right now it's too
polarizing it's too politically charged
it's too socially charged to talk about
that even if you believe that I don't I
don't mind even saying like I don't I
don't agree with him in the soccer I
believe it was like the soccer when he
was talking about the soccer teams but I
don't I don't necessarily believe that
in soccer I think women's soccer is very
uh entertaining but I believe that with
NBA basketball WNBA basketball I think
the NBA basketball is a thousand times
better than the WNBA aesthetically I'm
talking about how the game looks
and and it's already proven
teams that have won Championship
multiple championships in the WNBA the
teams have gone out of business there's
a report that the WNBA loses money every
single year Okay so
say whatever you want okay this ain't
the thing about women this is about a
product it's not it's not a it has not
proven to be a a profitable product okay
but again do you say that on air that's
just one of those things that you have
to just let go it's one of those things
that we all know but we're just not
going to talk about it you know because
we're because there's a greater good
here about
encouraging young girls to play sports
encouraging people to support women and
what they do you know so that there's
like a grander thing here and that's
what CNN represents that's what they you
know trying to do so for him saying that
sort of undermining that you know this
is the thing you talk about on podcasts
you know
you know what I'm saying like I don't
know if like you're one of the lead
anchors on a major News Network do you
say flipping comments without
following it up with some you know a
nuanced discussion so and then you know
this he he he's getting in trouble for a
bunch of things apparently you know
but but basically they're calling him a
misogynist and and all this and so now
he's out so that's what happened with
Don Lemon
and then you got our boy Tucker Carlson
Man Tucker
one I think the most polarizing news
news figure in since Bill O'Reilly who
got ousted right
these people all like hot when you get
high ratings you start feeling yourself
you start saying things so I don't watch
Fox News I don't like Hannity and these
kinds of things because to me I don't
like CNN either by the way I don't like
Rachel Maddow I don't like Donald I
don't like any sort of debate news thing
because this isn't the news they're not
reporting the news they're commenting on
the news and they're sitting at a news
table as if they're news reporters and
it's like yo you know this isn't the
news this is y'all you know Talking
Heads
that's basically a podcast what they're
doing what they've been doing for years
the news is different when they hit the
news they're reporting things that are
going on not commenting on things
they're just telling us what's going on
I like the news portions of both those
networks but this is ridiculous like
these people are the things that people
watch
and you know they're speaking to their
base
they're not challenging their base
they're just going on and I think I
think both Tucker and Don Lemon were
kind of like well you know
I don't know if I want to do that
anymore
feeling themselves
but at the same time if you're a Tucker
Carlson fan and I know that there's
people that watch podcast you might be a
Tucker Carlson fan I'm not anti-taco
Carlson okay I think that he has been
irresponsible in some of the things that
he says but now I'm starting to realize
this has more to do with CNN and fox
than it has to do with these two men
like they should start a podcast but
they should get together that'd be great
Don and Tucker they did a podcast oh my
God they'll be huge but anyways
so what happened with Taco Carlson all
right like I said this dude's a
polarizing figure man
so they got you know Fox was pushing
this whole thing that the election was a
fraud
they're talking about these software
companies that make the election things
and they said some disparaging things
about them and they caused issues you
know these companies were like yo we are
above reproach bro and we're suing so
they sued Fox two companies are suing
fox in the discovery
of suing Fox
their text messages and correspondences
with each other about this stuff they
had to give it up and wow
[Laughter]
all the text messages from the different
Fox people and you starting to go oh wow
there's what's really going on
Man Tucker Carlson
now here's what I have to feel about
Tucker now
I've always thought this about
conservative radio hosts conservative TV
personalities
there's so much money in it
I remember Glenn Beck
like I should go to the Forbes let me go
to this list right here real quick
because I remember this
um let me see
let's Let Me Go Forbes news anchor list
okay
let's see
um oh this is the under 30.
do you okay anyways anyways I remember
Glenn Beck was on this list and remember
Glenn Beck was considered a crazy person
he was just so right-wing and he was
pushing this agenda and then I was like
damn why is he is that I was like I
wonder does he really believe this stuff
right
then you look at the Forbes list and at
the time he was making 75 million
dollars
and I was like first 75 million dollars
a year I'll bash Obama you know what I
mean like how many of us could keep our
personal Integrity when that much money
is on the line
when when you have a network when you
have sponsors when you have things who
are telling you yeah for fire up the
base because it leads to 75 million
dollars
man I don't know I I don't know any of
you that would not do what these people
are doing
and I think Tucker was right in there I
think that if you're a fan of Tucker
Carlson let's say 80 of the time he's
has subjects on his show
that speak to you
especially like with the Trans issues
transgender issues or
toxic masculinity how he's sticking up
for men or or or if you believe in like
you know conservative issues he might be
your voice there might be you know he's
not it's not all crazy right he might be
your voice and you're like man that guy
speaks for me and I get that
but then and if you're a trump supporter
too and I know that there are a lot of
trump supporters out there more power to
you I'm no comment on that if you're if
you if you if you think that it is
better to have all of the baggage that
comes with and you still think with that
baggage I'd still rather have this
conservative person okay if you think
Trump did great fine and then you had
Tucker Carlson and Sean Hannity and
these guys are pushing that and you
think all right Tucker's on our side and
then these text messages come out man
it says a lot let's see uh I have the
text messages right here he goes he's
talking about Trump this is his own text
messages I hate him passionately
[Music]
we're all pretending we've got a lot to
show for it because admitting what a
disaster it's been is too tough to
digest but come on there's really isn't
an upside to Trump
what
man like if you're a trump supporter and
you're a Tucker constant supporter how
can you see that text and not feel lied
to and not feel like oh wow that this is
like
this just makes me disenchanted even
more with the news so you're telling me
that this guy is on air spewing stuff
and then secretly behind the scenes he's
like yeah I don't really like this guy
where's the Integrity in that
you know what I mean where's the
Integrity in that man it's like if
you're a staunch Trump supporter you
should feel lied to
you should feel like oh man so you
really you're just saying what I want to
hear but that's fine too I think Tucker
Carlson is a scapegoat so anyways listen
he gets the lawsuit from the uh the
voting machine company
they get this discovery they find these
texts
fox is like you know what Rupert
Murdoch's like settle
they're not gonna settle
they settle for almost a billion dollars
because they're like nah we we're not
given any more information just settle
another company is suing for almost two
billion dollars they're gonna win too
because these people are like you know
what
let's not give any more information just
settle sorry we messed up we're we're
admitting we we we uh we you know we we
we
misrepresented your companies and your
software and we're just gonna settle up
and then they fire Tucker he's a
scapegoat he's not even a problem Fox is
the problem they allowed all this to go
on
maybe he was like yeah I don't know
because maybe Tucker's behind the scenes
like why are we talking about Trump like
maybe we you know what's best for the
country like what is the news supposed
to be about
um you know what I'm saying like is it
about making money or is it about really
getting a a
honest discourse about stuff like you
could you could dislike the Republican
I'm sorry the Democrat agenda let's say
You're really conservative and you're
like I don't like this Democratic agenda
I understand that talk about it in that
way
but it seems to me they were just
talking about it in a way like let's
just speak to our base
police are advertisers
fire up the idiots that really aren't
informed which is most of us and then
tell people what they want to hear and
then let's move keep it moving
that's what they were doing because
behind the scenes they're texting each
other like can't wait to this guy's out
man
there's other texts
um in a text November 9th Carlson
referenced Powell's Dominion claims
commenting the software [__] is absurd
costs are then said on television that
night we don't know anything about the
software that many say was rigged we
don't know we ought to find out that's
what led to like the lawsuit right
like he's oh man there's so many there
was a good one let me find this one good
one uh oh he was calling people a [__] I
mean he was going in Tucker Carlson
uh on Trump's skipping Biden's
inauguration this is Tucker Carlson hard
to believe so destructive it's
disgusting I'm trying to look away like
like
I don't know if I like him or hate him
more
but I feel like I have a greater
understanding to of from my perspective
on Tucker Carlson
I feel like Tucker was just like a part
of the machine making a lot of money and
being like no okay and at the same time
but secretly being like ah come on Trump
what you doing man
you know what I mean like it sucks when
you see somebody doing something that
like half the time you like what they're
doing like you're like all right come on
we could do this uh let's push this
conservative agenda and then Trump will
do some stuff and he's like and he's
like I don't want to support that but
he's like in a situation where he's in a
News Network where he has to but now you
know how he really felt what does that
make you feel
what does it make you feel like if
you're a conservative right now I want
you to comment on this and dude let's
keep it let's keep it above board man we
don't got to be attacking each other and
all that kind of stuff I'm just saying
how honestly does it make you feel if
you're a conservative and you support
Trump how does it make you feel that
this guy you were listening to every
single night that had the highest
ratings he wasn't on the same page with
you fully as you thought what does that
make you feel about Fox News
it's like it just legitimizes everything
that all the Lefty comedians say about
Fox News you know you know they talk
about supposed to be fair and balanced
and it turns out these guys are behind
the scenes texting each other like we
ain't [__] this dude sucks what what are
we supposed to say about this
here's another one on the prospect of
ditching Trump coverage on Fox two days
before the capital Riot Carson wrote to
a colleague we are very very close to
being able to ignore Trump most nights I
truly can't wait the day after Trump
supporter you know you know then then
the day after Trump supporters he goes
Trump has two weeks left once he's out
he becomes incalculably less powerful
even in the minds of his supporters
a demonic force a destroyer but he's not
going to destroy us I've been thinking
about this every day for four years
that's from your dude's mouth
that's from you
highest ratings on the network
conservative people are like yeah Tucker
yeah he's my guy he's speaking for me
and behind the scenes he's saying that
how does that make you feel
crazy man
it is crazy
you can't trust CNN MSNBC you can't
trust Fox they all [__] and it's so
annoying
because there's people out there that
are just living their lives man there's
people out here they're just living
their lives they're paying their taxes
they're paying their bills and they just
want to turn on the TV and they want to
trust that these people have their best
interest at heart that they're just like
well let me find out yeah I'm more
conservative so let me watch Fox to see
what's going on and then they're spewing
all this stuff that they don't even
believe
they don't even believe it
and you're sitting at home being like
yeah yeah and he's and he's texting his
colleagues like this dude is demonic
those are his words about Trump demonic
man if you're a trump supporter you
should feel betrayed and you should
really wake up and be like whoa let me
let now I gotta find my news where do
you now check this out we can't even
trust the news sources where do we get
our news now where do we get it
you would like to think you turn on the
news they're telling us what's happening
and we can go oh okay now let me make a
judgment on my own they were pushing an
agenda they were pushing a feeling and
it is wrong
and it sucks that like these two men for
instance were put in this situation more
so Tucker calls into Don Lemon Don Lemon
just was he he was saying he was feeling
himself saying stuff with no context
with no Nuance with no no follow-up
discussion get out of here with that
[__] but Tucker Carlson
man and now he's the scapegoat you know
he's a scapegoat now he's just out here
like fox is like yeah well we let him go
uh he's the cause of you know he
shouldn't have said those things and now
we're gonna move on with business nah
man I find a problem with that you know
what I mean I I got I got I got a
problem with that uh I'm not a fan of
some of the things he talks about but I
am I am a believer that he should be
able to talk about it and then we have
an honest discourse about it afterwards
like I like that's why I think that it
would be great for them to start a
podcast or see Tucker with someone else
who's like has an opposing opinion and I
would love to see them discuss it
discuss it as opposed to pushing an
agenda
I mean it's crazy
like I'm telling you right now I want to
hear from you I know there's Trump
supporters that watch me because you
guys hit me up sometimes with your
spewing your hatred as opposed to just
having a discussion how do you feel now
how do you feel that the dude with the
highest ratings on the network that's
pushing an agenda how he really feels
man
come on y'all
let me read this again
okay this is his own words
Trump has two weeks left once he's out
he becomes incalculably less powerful
even in the minds of his supporters he's
a demonic force a destroyer but he's not
going to destroy us I've been thinking
about this every day for four years
let that sink in
conservative people Fox News people that
watch it
people that support Trump let that sink
in that you're talking head your voice
they were playing
his news broadcast in Russia because it
was they felt it was supporting them
that's how the dude really feels how
does that make you feel
wow
anyways
I
I want to drop my mic and be done with
this that's crazy okay that's all I got
to say about that all right we're done
with that
you know we're done with that I got to
get Tucker on Griffin with Griffin
wouldn't that be dope
uh
anyways guys
all right let's get to uh one of one of
my favorite things to do
is
there's some Instagram stories
um let's go to this one first
let's see so here's an Instagram story
that I thought was crazy let me see what
can we see it like this yeah oh man see
I have it set for like playing the
videos but I guess I could do it like
this here we go news and notes and
things all right so Rachel even showed
me this
Double toilet for lovers that love to do
everything together
no thank you
okay
get out of here with this
are you kidding me can you imagine
taking a [__] with your wife or
girlfriend
like what like this yeah I love
Rachel
and I'm always Furious when she goes to
the bathroom and leaves the door open I
don't care what she doing in there if
you sitting down the door should be
closed that's between you and your lord
okay close the door
I would not want to sit next to her
because my first of all even if somebody
said in the comments this is fake I mean
like because I know how
Rachel was that she would be all like
this is still available hold my hand
like she it's like
she
wants me to make everything she does
Disney princess
even taking a stinky dump I would have
to be like oh baby he's so cute over
there stinking up the bathroom you know
what I mean like why would you want to
do this like people are bananas man
you know what I mean like I just I have
a thing I don't know about you but it
took me a long time before I even
like like I didn't even want to go to
the bathroom like you know you know when
you're a couple a guy you know you walk
to the bathroom you just pull your thing
you pull your junk at you just go to
them you just pee
it took me a while before I was
comfortable in doing that you know but I
guess that's about my own insecurities
about myself you know what I mean
whatever it is it's like you know this
is my wife you know so it's like even
before we were just dating how long
before I was like comfortable with my
chubby body but I'm older so I was like
if somebody's into you they're into you
so I don't I didn't even think about it
anymore so you just you you know you
have confidence and you just do it but
then it just gets to a point where
you're like okay so when is it okay you
just pull it out and just be and now I
don't care you know what I mean but I'm
not at the point
I'm not I'm not at the point where I'm
in there taking a poop with the door
open I ain't there yet
it's you know it's like sitting on the
toilet and actually pooping you're like
Okay can somebody see you but when it's
time for cleanup I need to clean up on
my own I need to clean up with the door
closed you ain't watching me clean up so
I would not want to sit next to my wife
doing some cleanup that's crazy so that
was a crazy story
all right let's see what else we got
here
um
all right there was some other ones I
want to go to them this is from my
Instagram
if you have crazy stories on Instagram
you can send them to me too all right
this is now this is one I actually
wait let's see here
can we hear this
why can't we hear it
I want you to hear this crazy oh here we
go here we go here we go here we go all
right I want you guys to hear this
all right so this is a heated debate on
trans women in sports so this is a big
thing that's going on right now
a big thing going on right now is that
Congress is trying to pass a a law a
bill about trans athletes
playing especially for it and basically
it's about it's about biological men
becoming women and playing in women's
sports and now just just demolishing the
playing field okay it's really about
that you never hear about it in reverse
because you know just physically men are
faster stronger for the most part uh the
just the way with men are physically
built they're gonna be bigger stronger
than women so you never and if there's
some woman who's strong enough in fact
if that it would be unprecedented right
so it's like we don't hear about that
too so for the most part for the
majority of it that's that's the the
thing so there was this like heated
debate and uh I wanna I wanna show you
guys this and then we can talk about it
okay the Nuance of this all right trans
women are women
um so I I want to come at this from the
position of an athlete oh Jesus um so so
I play semi-pro basketball Semi-Pro
volleyball so when it comes to like
athletic spaces I don't think that trans
women should be allowed into athletic
spaces I think as female athletes we
work so incredibly hard for the little
opportunity there is in women's sports
would this be a barrier like this
there's no barrier there's less
opportunity in some Industries there's
less it's not no no no it's based on the
market okay hold on hold on guys okay
the problem is like
we can't compete we can't like I'm six
foot if I go up against a six foot guy
and I play basketball with him he's
gonna body me and what happens
even even if I have years more of
training and so it's like you're taking
away the little opportunity that we're
given and we all work so hard for we'll
be the end of women's sports have you
tried confidence Eli hold on sorry
confidence can't make me bench with a
guy benches
so hostile she's sharing her and
confidence
and I'd have to go no she's not she's
here she's a woman
your own experiences and your own
existence And yet when a woman is
sitting here telling you I feel as
though this is unfair and this is
compromising and the situation is not
helping women you guys are like but when
you're like I'm a black person that did
this this and this then it's valid and
fair and viable trans women oh man what
a a discussion
man
I I see we need more of this
in this PR on this particular subject
man
like
here's again it's a nuanced discussion
so you have this so I don't appreciate
how they were attacking this woman who
is trying to just say this is my truth
this is my experience
I feel like I'm going against a gup up
against people who have a great
advantage against me if you look at like
Leah Thomas okay Leah Thomas who was a
guy
biological man swimmer
going up against men getting
destroyed not good okay
becomes a woman or whatever you whatever
the proper terminology is for all the
people out there that support the
community I'm not trying to be
transphobic or whatever but you know you
have to watch your words because they'll
make anything you say transphobic even
me just talking about this they're gonna
be like this is problematic this is
problematic you know when they do that
it's like go [__] yourself okay I'm not
did you just then if that's what you
think then get out of here but anyways
then this guy
reveals himself and is like now I'm a
woman
and it competes against women and it's
and and they can't compete
just a common sense
of this
why can't we just have a discussion
about all right
maybe there should be a different
category or maybe there should be some
sort of algorithm like they do with golf
I've talked about this before and I'm
just going to talk about it again
when you're on a golf course they have a
men's tee and they have a woman's tea
maybe you think that's fair maybe you
think it's not fair but they're
basically saying like all right the
women shoot from here to men shoot from
there and when they compete against each
other that's how somehow they're
leveling the playing field
it's like spotting somebody's uh you
know some seconds
you know it's like when you're you're
racing against your little brother you
go okay I'm gonna give you a five second
Head Start that's leveling the playing
field find some way
but the woman's saying like in
basketball I don't have a chance
but let's just be like even Trump in his
craziness made a joke about it he was
like yeah I would want to coach a
women's basketball team and I would ask
LeBron James to be become a woman and
then I'd have the greatest basketball
team ever yeah like think about that
you see we don't what if there is an NBA
player who is trans
like what if Zion Williams is like you
know what I'm a woman
and Zion Williams goes to the NBA
what are you gonna say then
what are you gonna say
what are you gonna look at this and make
this whole thing about trans women are
women okay that's a feeling okay that's
like all right we're saying you want to
live your life this way
just because you want to live your life
this way doesn't mean that now the rest
of us have to be like well okay but you
know this person was this uh you know
when we go into the laboratory and look
at the body structure and bone structure
and muscle configuration this person has
an advantage it's like
it's like it's like why can't we just
have a common sense discussion like that
without it turning into a thing where we
think we're hating on these people no
we're just kind of saying like yeah we
want you to live your truth
but just because you live in your truth
don't mean you get to play sports
like I said this before Leah Thomas
should just go down to the YMCA and swim
you want to swim go down to the YMCA we
ain't stopping you from swimming but
when you're competing against biological
women who don't have the same advantage
of you I think it's okay to have a pause
and go hey let's let's figure this out
this is new this is a new thing let's
figure out what we're gonna do instead
of like these people yelling at each
other and and then the one woman made a
terrific point
as a as a mixed race person okay as a as
a
black person you know whatever my
percentage you know
you know what I mean
that's a fair point the ladies making
because if it was about if it was a
black person standing sitting there
talking about like the advantages that
we don't have and they've been taken
away because of racism or whatever like
that everybody would have to listen to
be like well we gotta do something about
this
but when a woman like where are the
people fighting for the rights of women
it's crazy like you know when you hear
these stories
you know you hear these stories about
um
locker rooms now
like there's women in locker rooms right
there in their locker room and then they
look up and there's like a dick in the
locker room okay they're just like oh my
God this person has a dick and then the
person is it calm down I'm a woman you
know and then they're like okay but
they've been talking a whole lot to be
afraid of dicks
okay you know what I mean you're in the
locker room chilling and then there's
you're not used to this and you're just
like okay well
you know
you have a dick and then so now
as a as a society now we have to just be
okay with this you know because if
you're you're not okay with it it means
you're hateful that's what they'll tell
you right you know what's crazy though
is you don't you don't
maybe there are these stories but
they're never publicized
you never hear about the 120 pound
biological woman
with her butt ass naked in the men's
locker room
walking around
you know walking around with her vagina
and breasts telling all these naked men
like hey guys
I'm a man
uh so everybody chill out I wonder why
you don't hear about that a lot
you know what I mean why don't you hear
about that you never hear about the you
know
you never hear about them and you know
you're walking in the men's locker room
but ass naked like hey hey what's up
guys because maybe they wouldn't feel
safe
maybe that man would be like okay
because maybe they're gonna that like
you could tell me what you are
but these naked men in this locking room
what do they see
they see titties
in a vagina
now I'm not saying that that gives
anybody car Blanche to do whatever they
want but
there's a there's an issue you would be
like oh let me not be in this would you
want to be alone
if you were a 130 pound
man with a vagina and and you would you
want to be alone in the steam room with
some dude you don't know
you never hear about that
you know what I mean because they would
be like no I wouldn't feel safe so why
is it then
then women in locker rooms they feeling
the same thing they don't know this
person they just see a dick and they're
like you have a dick so whoa can I take
a Beat
and uh see how I feel about this
it's so crazy where we're at with this
right now that we can't have
common sense
compassionate
for both sides nuanced discussion
so we can
coexist
and have some understanding together
right now it has to be so
polarizing one side other side and I
don't like it
I don't like it
anyways y'all
um wow that was like a quick ass hour
you know what I mean
Daddy was into it today
um I just I I just if you guys if you
have
any comments again I really appreciate
I'd love to see comments this week about
your thoughts especially from my
conservative Roofing with Griffin fans
uh and even other ones too just how we
all should start feeling now about the
news then like where should we get our
news and and how do you feel when you
know hearing this guy that you know was
your voice
sort of just secretly not really
agreeing with you maybe you think he's a
patriot because he was like this is
what's best for the country so even if I
don't feel this way I'm gonna do it but
I don't know I don't know how that makes
you feel uh I'm just telling you that's
I I would feel us I would feel some kind
of way about that all right
once again I want to thank you for
watching riffing with Griffin you know
guys make sure you sub I'm here every
Wednesday sometime on Wednesday between
10 and 1 I'm gonna try to get on live
I'm gonna try to make it more consistent
I'm on Twitch most days come check me
out patreon love y'all
um you know
thanks for being here you know what I
mean thanks for all the support and I
appreciate everybody that comes and
enjoys the podcast you know what I mean
so wait what's going on with this
where's my main titles oh there they are
anyways so you know what time it is
y'all
uh
uh yeah it's that rap recap rap recap
whoa
[Music]
that's all I got for that
Tucker
turned out a [__]
out at Rucker Park
you versus him
you don't know what's in him
he didn't like Trump
thought that fool was a dump
[Music]
let's stick up for women
so they could get back to winning
[Music]
the NBA
I hope my clippers go all the way but
they love
there's no boss
what car
[Music]
yeah here on Griffin
and I see you next week
um
everybody see you next week
[Music]
foreign